as long as human beings have been around
i could imagine that they've noticed
that offspring tend to have traits in
common with the parent for example
someone might have told you hey you walk
kind of like your dad or your smile is
kind of like your mom or or your your
eyes are like well you're one of your
uncles or or your grandparents and so
there's always been this notion of
inherited traits but it wasn't until the
1800s that that started to be studied in
a more scientific way with gregor mendel
mendel the the father of genetics but
even then even mendel who was starting
to understand the the mechanisms of or
he was trying to understand how
inheritance happens and he even could
start to breed certain types of things
even he didn't know exactly what was the
molecular basis for inheritance and the
answer to that question wasn't figured
out until fairly recent times until the
mid 20th century not until the structure
of dna was established by watson and
crick and their work was based on the
work of many others especially folks
like rosalind franklin who who
essentially provided the bulk of the
data for watson crick's work maurice
wilkins and many many many other folks
but it's really the the structure of dna
that made people say hey that looks like
the mo that looks like the molecule that
that's storing the information just to
be clear dna wasn't discovered in 1953
dna was discovered in the mid-1800s
it was this kind of this this molecule
that was inside of of of of nuclei of
cells and for some time people said oh
maybe this could be the a molecular
basis of inheritance you know you can
imagine what you would need to be a
molecular basis of inheritance it would
have to be a molecule or a series of
molecules that could contain information
that could be replicated that could be
expressed in some way
but it wasn't until 1953 when this
double helix structure of dna was
established that people said hey this
looks like this looks like our molecule
so first let's just talk about the
structure here and then actually we'll
talk about where this name dna
deoxyribonucleic
acid comes from and then we'll talk a
little bit about why why the structure
lends itself well to something that
stores information that can replicate
its information and that could express
its information we might go in depth on
the expression of information in future
videos so this structure right over here
and this is a visual depiction of a dna
molecule you can view this as kind of a
twisted ladder it has these two i guess
you could say sides of the ladder that
are twisted that is one side right over
there and then it is another side
there's another side right over here
and in between
in between those two sides are
connecting those two sides of that
twisted ladder you have these rungs and
these rungs are actually where the
information the genetic information is i
guess you could say stored in some way
because these rungs it's a sequence of
different bases and when i say basis
that you say wait this says acid why are
you saying bases right over here well
the word
deoxyribonucleic acid comes from the
fact that this backbone is made up of a
combination of sugar and phosphate and
the the the sugar that makes up the
backbone is deoxyribose so that's
essentially the d in dna
and then the phosphate group is acidic
and that's so where you get the acid
part of it
and nucleic is hey this was found in
nuclei of cells it is nucleic acid
deoxyribone
acid but it's not it also it is it is
actually mildly acidic all in total but
for every acid it actually also has a
base and that base for those bases form
the rung of the ladders and actually
each rung is a pair of bases and as i
said that's where the information is
actually stored what am i talking about
well let me talk about the four
different bases that make up the rungs
of a dna molecule
so you have adenine
adenine
and so for example this part right over
here this
this this section of that rung might be
adenine maybe this right over here is
adenine
this right over here remember each of
these rungs are made up by
it's a pair of bases
and that might be adenine maybe
this is adenine
and i could stop there oh i mean i'll do
a little more adenine maybe that's
adenine right over there and adenine
always pairs with the base thymine
so let me write that down so i adenine
pairs with thymine
thymine
so if that's an adenine there then this
is going to be a thymine
if this is an adenine then this is going
to be a thymine or if i drew the thymine
first well i'll say okay it's going to
pair with the adenine so this is going
to be a thymine right over here this is
going to be a thymine if i were to draw
this this would be a thymine right over
here now the other two bases you have
cytosine which pairs with guanine or
guanine that pairs with cytosine so
guanine and we're not going to go into
the the the molecular structure of these
bases just yet although these are good
good names to know because they show up
a lot and they really form kind of the
code your genetic code
guanine
guanine pairs with cytosine
guanine and cytosine
cytosine
so actually if this is let's say there's
some cytosine there let's say cytosine
right over here maybe this is cytosine
maybe this is cytosine
maybe this is cytosine this is cytosine
and maybe this is cytosine then it
always pairs with the guanine if we're
talking so let's see this is guanine
then and this will be guanine this is
guanine this is guanine i actually
didn't draw stuff here but this is
guanine i didn't say what these could be
but these would
these would be made of pairs of they
could be adenine thymine pairs and it
could be adenine on either side or the
thymine on either side and they could be
made of guanine cytosine pairs where the
guanine or the cytosine is on the other
side actually just to make it a little
bit more complete let me just let me
just color in
the rungs here as best as i can
so that's those are guanine so they're
going to pair with cytosine pair with
cytosine pair with cytosine and when
it's drawn this way you might start to
see how this is essentially a code the
order of which the bases uh are are
i guess the
order in which the we have these the seq
or the sequence of these bases
essentially encode the information that
make you you and you could debate well
how much of it is nature versus nurture
and when people say nature you know it's
literally genetic and that's that's an
ongoing bait an ongoing debate but it
does code for things like your hair
color uh
you know when you see that your smile is
similar to your your parents it is
because that information to a large
degree is encoded genetically it can
affect it affects a lot of what makes
you you and actually not even just
within a species but also cross
across species what humans have more
genetic material in common with other
humans than they do with say a plant but
all living creatures as we know them
have genetic information this is the
basis by which they are passing down
their actual traits
now you might be saying well how much
genetic information does a human being
have and the number will will either
disappoint you or or you might find it
mind mind boggling the human genome the
human genome and every species has a
different number of base pairs to a
large degree correlated with how complex
they are although not always but the
human genome the human genome has 6
million
sorry not 6 million 6 billion
6 million would be disappointing even
billion might be disappointing 6 billion
base pairs
6 billion
6 billion base pairs and when you have
your full complement of chromosomes and
this is in most of your the cells in
your body and outside of your your your
your sex cells or your the sperm or or
the egg cells
this is going to be spread over 46
46 chromosomes
46 chromosomes or i guess you'd say 23
pair of chromosomes if you divide 6
billion by 46 you get a little over on
average 100 milli i think it's 100 and
something million
base pairs per chromosome and some
chromosomes are longer actually the
longest or over 200 million and some
might be shorter that's just on average
now this number might to some of you
might be exciting you're like oh i did i
thought i was a simple creature i didn't
know i was i was this complex 6 billion
that's a lot of base pairs that feels
like a lot of information
for others of you it might not feel so
great you might say hey wait i could i
could store this much information on a
modern thumb drive or on a hard disk i
thought i was i thought i was i was more
more unique than that and of course we
all are special and unique but you might
say only six million base pairs i
thought i was you know i was infinitely
complex and whatever else and and
there's some arguments for that in along
some some other directions but this is
on the the
the approximate length i guess you could
say the approximate size of the actual
human genome and when we talk about
chromosomes and we'll talk about
chromosomes much in much more depth
depth imagine taking this this zoomed in
thing that you have right over here
and you know over here i don't know how
many we have like one two three four
five six seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 19. we have about 20 base
pairs depicted here imagine if you had
about 200 million of these base pairs
and then you were to take this thing and
you were to kind of coil it up into that
thing is a
is a chromosome is a chromosome and
you're saying wait i have that much
information in most of the cells of my
body this thing must be incredibly
compact and if you said that i would say
yes you are correct this
this the radius the radius of the dna
molecule is on the order of one
nanometer
one
nanometer which is a billionth of a
meter so you can start to assess kind of
the scale of this thing this is a very
dense way to actually store information
but just to have an appreciation of and
you might have seen it when i was
coloring in on on why the structure
lends itself to
being able to replicate the information
or even to be able to translate or
express the information
let's think about if you were to take
this ladder and you were to just kind of
split all the base pairs so you just
have one half of them so you essentially
have half of the ladder and so if you
only have half of the ladder you're able
to construct the other half of the
ladder let's let's take an example let's
say and i'll just use the the first
letter to abbreviate for each of these
bases so let's say you have some so
let's say this is one of the this is the
sugar phosphate backbone right over here
so this could be one of the one of the
sides let's say there's some adenine
actually let me do them in the right
color
so you got some adenine adenine maybe
some adenine right over here
maybe there's an adenine there maybe you
have some
thymine thymine
maybe thymine right over here
then you have some
you have some guanine guanine
guanine and then let's say you have some
cytosine and you have some cytosine so
if with just half of the of this of this
ladder i guess you could say you're able
to construct the other half and that's
actually how dna replicates this ladder
splits and then each of those two halves
of that ladder are able to construct
versions of the other half or versions
of the other half are able to be
constructed on top of that on top of
that half so how does that happen
well it's based on how these bases pair
adenine always pairs with thymine if
we're talking about dna so if you have
an a there you're gonna have a t on this
end t on this end
t's right all over here t right over
there if you have a t on that end you're
gonna have an a right over there a a
if you have a g a guanine on this side
you're gonna have a cytosine on the
other side cytosine cytosine cytosine
and if you have a cytosine you're gonna
have a guanine on the other side and so
hopefully that gives you an appreciation
of how dna can replicate itself and as
we'll see also how this information can
be translated to other forms of either
related molecules but eventually to
proteins and just to kind of round out
this video to get a real visual sense
what the dna molecule looks like or it
gets a different visual depiction from
this
i found this
this animated that's animated gif that
you know if you haven't fully digested
what a double helix looks like this is
it
and you see here you see your sugar
phosphate bases here you see kind of the
sugars and phosphate uh the sugars and
the phosphates alternating along this
backbone and then the rungs of the
ladder are these base pairs so this is
one of the bases that's the
corresponding that's this corresponding
i guess you could say partner and you
could see that along all the way up and
down this molecule very exciting